made it just made a pizza for lunch and
it's [ __ ] I'm just blowing up man
just and it was just a single like we
made her a mushroom pizza and just like
the size of a dinner plate and I made a
mushroom and pepperoni one I was gonna
put it in the damn right in the damn
cookbook but I don't know if I can do it
to y'all I might just do all kinds of
damage no you gotta do pizza cuz that's
like what your boys famous for like cuz
you make everything from scratch once I
teach them how to take flour and turn
that into pizza dough easily once you
get confident with it then a pizza only
costs a few sets to make I always
thought the sauce was harder than that
yeah do because it's hard to get the
balance right between like well the
tartness and the sugar yeah once salt
the salt the sugar and then like you
know the you know I didn't use wine in
that one but I did use seasonings when
you make when you make a pot of sauce
you make a bunch of it
yeah and that's gonna be the base for a
bunt for a spaghetti sauce or oh yeah
you own a huge pile like every make me
make that make a big pot that way you
don't have to do very much of it and you
can freeze some of it and you can bring
it out as you need it and change it into
whatever you want I'll put sauce recipe
in there yeah but sauce doesn't do that
much damage well it does all that damn
biological damages pizza crust you get
fat as [ __ ] making pizza and even though
I've been keeping the diet pretty good
and I make a [ __ ] pizza it's just all
those calories hitting it once just like
boom it's like we don't eat the well
probably that's why because we don't eat
that much every day and so when we do
like splurge and actually make a pizza
man I'm very uncomfortable but it's good
I feel like you got me pregnant or I did
with a turkey baster I was asleep [ __ ]
I'm gonna sue you I was raped
you're gonna give birth to a little tiny
Thomas no she's like something mother
like basket case Belial yeah we saw I
ordered I ordered some old movies the
other day I got all 5 Superman movies on
DVD for like 5 bucks brand-new wraps
that's it man I wanted to see Superman 3
again been a long time since I've seen
it was [ __ ] corneas [ __ ] I couldn't
get through it I do want to see Superman
4 because that was a cannon flick and
that was like the worst one and that was
what was that what was that [ __ ] to
call some rather the piste and I don't
know they had some bad guy in there
looks like a damn wrestler like a blond
wrestler yeah what was that guy is that
I forgot it was fogging the quest for
peace right that's for peace something I
remember seeing it as a candy and on TV
and it looked like something that was
made for TV back then I was like what
the [ __ ] man as Superman has degenerated
to that I didn't remember part 3 being
that bad but I did remember not being as
good as 1 & 2 that's what I remembered
something I saw it a bunch times that's
the one with Richard Pryor I think what
ended up happening was that you got
Richard Lester directing it who was more
famous for doing like you know the
Beatles like help and hard days I like
comedies type stuff yeah so he wanted to
go like in a more slapstick e direction
and that's why they got Richard Pryor
but Richard Pryor wanted to be wanted a
more serious role because you might
wanted to yeah because he loved Superman
and he wanted to be like in you know
more serious movie and not him to kind
of get away from comedy a little bit so
the tone of it was kind of strange had
they kept Donner yeah with Pryor that
would have been [ __ ] awesome because
that Pryor's character is a more serious
character would have fit well with the
tone of Superman Pryor was right yeah
about the way Superman 3 should have
been but there was enough there in
Superman 3 where that could have been a
great movie yeah there was there's still
some good [ __ ] that's just not great
yeah one was [ __ ] epic 2 was really
good especially the special Donner cut
that's that's really good too
even though both cuts were good three is
okay it's not great though yeah and I
remember for being horrible all right
thank you but I want to see it because
it's a can
movie and I remember it getting
hilarious yeah I might take it I might
have a newfound appreciation for it
oh we're gonna know but anyway once you
get all liquored up and the other one I
ordered was airplane one and two yeah
because I grew up with airplane one and
I wanted to see if it was as funny as I
remembered it and it was yeah yeah we
watched airplane one less I haven't seen
airplane two in a long time yet airplane
twos got the shat in it and I don't
think I've ever seen it I saw it read
it's been years
I mean airplane one like when we watch I
haven't seen it for probably two decades
but when we watched it again last night
I remembered almost every single yeah
line to stuff in the backgrounds
actually we're all a funny shitty well
that's what I mean that's what makes it
so funny is that it's not drawing
attention to itself like hey look here's
the funny [ __ ] it's like most of the
funniest gags or like kind of happen in
the background and they don't really
draw attention to it there's layers of
funny yeah and it's just like everyone's
very serious and like plays it very
straight which I think which makes it
funnier to me yes like the [ __ ] about
[ __ ] Kareem abdul-jabbar being the
co-pilot yeah and then the kids breaking
his character hey aren't you Kareem
abdul-jabbar and I say no I'm Roger
I'll show you oh man [ __ ] oh man says
you're a bum oh man then I'd like to see
his ass bust is a bust his ass [ __ ]
what is it for 44 48 minutes so I can
run up and down that damn Court well the
funniest gag to like other than him
breaking character and actually being
Kareem abdul-jabbar Persian they take
him away when they like when he
inexplicably like has his glasses like
his goggles guys guy they take about
nice got like his basketball shorts and
knee pads knee pads on because nobody
cuz nobody says anything about it nobody
dros ynni touch it's just kind of
happens and they're like and it just
keeps I got them because we watched that
[ __ ] exorcism at 20,000 feet and then
like a couple days later [ __ ] Oliver
Harper did a thing on airplane no said
it was cinematic Santa Massacre that's
what it was
do the thing on airplane and I was like
God how much they loved it I guess like
man I gotta see that you're like man we
haven't seen that in a million years
yeah
so they had I wasn't gonna buy it on
blu-ray but yeah I got I got the set of
two on DVD for like five bucks so how
the hell are you gonna say no to
airplane one and two for 5 bucks
delivered yeah although I've forgotten
how much I loved Robert Stack in it yeah
it's funny like he was so [ __ ] funny
like what my favorite thing was when he
was like China when he was talking to
Ted over the [ __ ] TV and then like he
was saying this like you gotta build him
up he's gotta you know what I mean but
do up his confidence and said have you
ever flown a 400 playing poor he goes no
we do [ __ ] yeah
what about when what about when they
bring the boy into the cockpit and the
[ __ ] camera starts hitting on the
Peter you ever seen a grown man naked
glad he's picking up on a boy and then
the other one the little boy is all
[ __ ] proper gives that a girl a cup of
coffee he had first of all when she
walks in he [ __ ] eyes are up and down
from that and he's reading like I want
the Economist or some [ __ ] he's looking
at that little girl's ass and [ __ ] but
you couldn't get away with that today
but [ __ ] he's that girl's ass oh [ __ ]
and then later on they show him in the
movie he shows up [ __ ] being mr.
gentleman with a [ __ ] tray and a cup
of coffee would you like a cup of coffee
yes sure you know any stay in there go
ahead have a seat she sits down and she
goes I like you know just would you like
cream and sugar because no I like it
black like men [ __ ] him boy gets cut
down and they're only in it for like
like a serious like to see yeah that's
the whole [ __ ] scene those two scenes
that's what I mean it's like yeah they
had a lot of [ __ ] sex jokes it [ __ ]
in there yeah [ __ ] on your face and
wiggle yeah and like I said everything
is just played completely straight and
like nothing is for marked upon nothing
is like nobody reacts like oh my god I
can't believe you just like everyone
just like like you didn't even say
anything win that's what that's what's
so funny barbara billingsley [ __ ] he
shows up excu
you stir it as I speak John is jumbo
don't want to have jumbo don't get
[ __ ] beavers mom's [ __ ] [ __ ]
movies hilarious
it really is yeah age already well it
did actually jets flying through a night
and a good plan propeller noises me the
funniest [ __ ] is just like not real is
you know they're talking about the war
and he's a young guy and they keep
showing World War two imagery they start
going back to like the right one he was
a history was stationed in Drambuie
yeah and Captain God deployed the
daiquiri yeah and I think what it's
because I haven't seen it since I was a
kid so like a lot of stuff I didn't I
guess I didn't like appreciate when I
was a lot younger like some of the jokes
about [ __ ] you know and the one get
like the one guy that's in the [ __ ]
hospital like military hospital it's
like he thinks he's Ethel Merman and
they go they really jump site is
actually create just a singer yeah yeah
and they [ __ ] jump on her and trying
to restrain her and she's sucking doing
a show - yeah we're trying to pull her
back on her bed so many up bags are up
with the needle puts a needle talking
slowing up [ __ ] funny okay
I had actually hoped that it would hold
up in it a lot of drug humor why it's a
bad time to stop sniffing glue yeah but
can be went from smoking no drinking
coffee
no smoking drinking drinking I thought I
was drinking coffee first
no no it wasn't no start smoking yeah
yeah yeah picked a bad times to quit
smoking he's too smoking and then drank
it and drinking and then [ __ ] ass
sniffing glue no sniffing glue was the
last one okay well I am feta mean yeah
I knew it was like something yeah it's
not cocaine what kind of plane is
engaging oh it's a big beautiful white
plane it deals in red yeah all of it
which part to some other day I saw Mel
Brooks history of the world part one I
sawed clips of it like a year ago two
years ago I yeah I couldn't get through
it it didn't hold up
I'd have to watch it again I haven't
seen that since I was a kid either
I recent junk Frankenstein about eight
years ago it was held up but now Young
Frankenstein is still funny yeah I think
but not history of the world
I think Mel was on too much coke and it
ain't had too much to do with took in
the early 80s I think it was humor of
its time airplanes just [ __ ] nuts
there's nothing there's no way you
there's nothing that really grounds it
at any time the only thing that didn't a
person I think that I think the only
joke that would go over the average
person's head today because when the
stewardess comes by and asks the guy
would you like another cup of coffee
this yeah I'll have another one and the
woman goes phone never has a second cup
of coffee at home and nobody would know
what that is but that was a Folgers
commercial yeah well motor sinker
Shanker's I can't was like some coffee
commercial that's all it was yeah you
had to know that they did make some like
kind of timely references that you like
a couple jokes about a [ __ ] Gerald
Ford and like yeah whose [ __ ] that was
like on going on at the time that maybe
people wouldn't remember nowadays but
you know it's kind of the same thing
that happens with Mystery Science
Theater it's like some of their
references they make refer the [ __ ]
different commercials from the seventies
and sixties and stuff that maybe a lot
of people wouldn't remember but they
remembered I mean I'm from their time
and I don't know half of what the [ __ ]
they're talking about you need a team of
people to go through ms-13 to actually
totally decode all of it it's the
knowledge of a bunch of people it is
yeah well they had to lead a whole bunch
of writers right and they did [ __ ] that
the average person didn't do like read a
whole bunch of [ __ ] old books yeah
you know I mean if I can they actually
have I think websites on there that
explain everything they [ __ ] said I'm
on yeah I've been on like the mst3k
discussion boards forum and there is a
whole like hundreds and hundreds of page
you know topic where it's like you're
asking people like hey explain this
reference yeah what is it me you know
what I mean so it's but you know like I
said most of this stuff every now and
then they'll refer to something that I'm
not that I don't know what they're
talking about but probably ninety ninety
five percent of the time I know what
they're talking about either because I
remember it or because I got it through
like a secondhand source you know what I
mean was there anything else we had to
cover no I wanted to say that because
we've been talking about you know doing
the you the sidetracks thing and
everything like that and we're still
gonna do that budget and we're still
gonna put at least one thing up every
day yeah but I decided that what I
wanted to do instead of because
sometimes like when we do the sidetracks
we don't have a [ __ ] ton of stuff to
talk about and sometimes we watched like
a new movie the night before and we
can't talk about it because we're saving
it to like review it for the meditation
which that doesn't really I decided well
that doesn't really make a lot of sense
and it doesn't make a lot of sense to
just save everything and put it all on
one show like the one matinee show on
Sunday so I think what we might start
doing is just putting up multiple
matinees like during the week so it's
like if we'll probably still watch three
new movies a week you know they'll be
set them up individually instead of like
saving them and that means the archives
a lot cleaner too it'll be it'll be
based on the video will be based on one
movie only yeah and that way you're
getting one at least one video from us a
day yeah and the quality of it will be a
lot better than that's just saying well
we have to do a daily one and then we
have to do this thing now we're gonna
combine it into like there's gonna be
the main show and then there's gonna be
something that goes up every day it'll
either be or it might be it might be a
sidetrack it might be an old movie it
might be a movie retrospective um you
know so it'll be one of our things but
it'll be up every day yeah that way
because you know the whole side track
thing was something we just
pulled out our ass-fucking at the last
minute because of the pandemic where we
said we were gonna [ __ ] give you guys
some more content get you through the
pandemic
well pandemics coming to an end week you
can tell because a lot of people are
starting to go back to work and our
views on them are starting to decline
because there's other [ __ ] to do now so
we're gonna we're gonna readjust the
material to compensate for all that yeah
that way we'll keep is that we're gonna
go more for quality and over quality
over volume because the pandemics over
well I'm just saying that we want
something going up every day but it
might not necessarily right side tracks
might be a movie on view it'll be a high
quality poor or something like that or
it could be a sidetrack it could be
whatever it could be whatever but we
will put something up every day it's
just you know we're just decided to do
it like that because like I said but
particularly the matinee show I was
thinking well it does seem dumb cuz
sometimes we've talked to people and we
said hey we saw this new movie yeah and
then they have to wait until Sunday
you're gonna like for us to review it
whereas we could like just review as
soon as it comes out and that's how
we're gonna do um you know what I mean
so we we just did it under force a habit
anyway because that's just the way we
used to do it so well yeah we just
started doing it like that because we
had AMC a list of like we went to the
theater and it's like we initially
started like recording the reviews like
while we were at the theater and then we
just put them all together at the end of
the week um but it doesn't really make
sense for us to do it like that anymore
because you know we're here all the time
all the [ __ ] we watch is streaming yeah
so as soon as we watch new [ __ ] let's
review it and put it up like the next
day or the day after or whatever and
then we'll do retrospective - it'll be
just like it was yeah I mean that that
stuff is all gonna be the same I'm just
saying that like on the days when we
don't have a big show like the main show
or the movie retrospective it'll either
be a matinee bigot or sidetracks or
maybe a movie retrospectively or maybe a
stream yeah or maybe a live stream or
some device it's like we'll do something
every day it's just night we might
change it up a little bit that's all so
it's you know pry out a star
live-streaming yeah I gotta like figure
out gotta find out how they do it
I have enough [ __ ] I got to do that
probably our first live stream you will
see from us will be an experimental live
stream that you might may or may not
catch and then we'll take it down
ya know an experiment because like I
said I wanted to do one sometime around
the 200th yeah episode which is only a
few weeks away okay
so but we might do an experimental one
before that just to make sure that
everything is awfully and once we get to
hang hang of streaming probably we might
be able to do that other than to and
like get out I mean we could do the
reviews during the stream yeah that's
true we could you know and just
streamline everything yeah I mean I do
like the for the matinee show
particularly another thing I wanted to
do too was I noticed that some of the
shows like the regular episodes and the
matinee have little intros like little
music or whatever and then the other
[ __ ] doesn't have that so I figured what
I was gonna do was I was just gonna so I
I was gonna make like a couple second
little intro like for the witching hour
for the movie retrospective for so
everything will just have it a little
little set right you know what I may
need to do the same for a stream too and
also understand I think you can choose
background music and graphics which we
need to get on all that too because I
like when I watch other people stream I
like that yeah it does a little bit
background music in the back yeah you
know I think I think that program
handles that well yeah we'll definitely
be looking into that that's right it's
like I said I will do an experimental
want to see how it's gonna work out and
if we if I can use this computer which
is old or if I can use the other
computer which is I mean you guys know
about stream and I want to point us in
the right direction you can go ahead and
leave it in the comments section too
yeah yeah but it starts up once you
start streaming I think that'll open up
a different customer base too because
there are some people that just like
just that yeah it's like an augmented
reality that's what's this guy leaning
one of our subscribers said it was like
augmented reality that way they can they
can make comments live and get answers
live yeah I don't know and it's kind of
a different experience and some people
are looking for just that yeah once that
goes you know [ __ ] we can use help
people sharing sharing our streams yeah
try to get more subscribers yeah
we'd do it online [ __ ] and I do like the
idea of like being able to like answer
people's questions yeah you see us uncut
anyway mostly this stuff isn't edited
yeah I mean even all pretty much all the
reviews we do all the episodes we do I
very very rarely take anything out yeah
the only time I take anything out is if
I totally spaced and like lose my place
in the notes or you know drinking all
night and I'll sing God use the restroom
or yeah like suddenly he'll be like I
gotta pee yeah never think the
livestream I'd go home I'll be back in a
minute
cuz I think I just have fun during a
live stream yeah you probably add the
[ __ ] up yeah I know you may be running
by probably by the end of it you'd be
flinging poop around like a monkey no
we'd be doing I'll be doing the [ __ ]
sand ow [ __ ] strip taking a [ __ ]
Hoppus and down you know I'm gonna get
that bad mmm
no yeah do the show tonight anyway we I
do the show night what time is it it's 3
o'clock ok soon we're gonna start as
soon as we're gonna have to start
recording the show yeah we're gonna
we're gonna put this up and then we're
gonna take a little break and then we're
gonna start the main show and I got a
digest all this piece no it's just kind
of sitting there I know just may push it
back a little bit later we'll see no
well don't leave it too late yo cuz I
got up like really early it's like I'll
probably fall asleep midship leave it
too late all right I'm down a quickness
[ __ ] I quit this [ __ ] here Friday and
we'll probably talk to you guys again
tomorrow